there have been a lot of Avengers for
leaks lately we have seen leaked set
photos leaked concept art photos leaked
toy photos and descriptions and most
recently a supposedly
for the first Avengers 4 trailer coming
out if you haven't heard or read the
description for the trailer yet you can
check out a video I did on it in the
link above I'm also still giving out
copies of infinity war and ant-man and
the wasp on blu-ray and some special
edition posters all you have to do to
enter the giveaway is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so the trailer
description is really awesome and it's
actually quite long but there is one
part in the trailer description that I'm
glad they mentioned because I've been
thinking about this for a while now and
that is Iron Man giving Captain America
his shield at the end of Captain America
Civil War Tony tell Steve that the
shield doesn't belong to him that it
belonged to his father doesn't belong to
you
you don't deserve it my father made that
you
Steve then drops the shield and leaves
it behind and he still doesn't have his
shield and Avengers infinity war Steve
Rogers and Tony Stark never crossed
paths it's likely that Tony would have
given Steve his shield back considering
the circumstances of infinity war but
they never cross paths so he ended up
using shields that T'Challa gave him
however Tony does have a shield waiting
for Steve and it's most likely been
really enhanced Tony has had captain
shield for a few years now and he's also
been preparing for an invasion since the
events of the first Avengers movie he
made upgrades to his suit with nanotech
the same a Spider Man suit so he most
likely did the same with Captain shield
and let's not forget about the scene in
spider-man homecoming where happy is
transporting some items from Avengers
tower to the New Avengers headquarters
and he casually mentions that one of
these items is a new shield for Captain
America he also mentions a new belt for
Thor but I'll save that for another
video so a new shield for Captain
America that means that this is not the
same shield it's probably physically the
same shield but it's definitely been
altered and enhanced by stark technology
this probably means that there's some
nanotech in there but what I actually
think that they're going to get at in
Avengers 4 is Captain America's energy
shield and I think that they'll somehow
incorporate this with nanotechnology as
well the energy shield is made up of
cooled plasma and comes out of a
wristband that the user wears not only
is this shield obviously great at
protection but it can also be used as
controllable projectile weapons and it
can morph into other forms if needed
such as a staff sword or rope so that's
an easy way to include nanotechnology
into the shield whatever the user thinks
of the nano bytes become it's definitely
more advanced than captain's original
shield but it actually takes the shape
of his original shield so it's the best
of both worlds
the story in the comics of the energy
shield actually kind of lines up with a
story in the MCU right now in the comics
Steve wields the energy shield after the
events of Civil War Steve is actually
presumed to be dead and when he comes
back he finds that Bucky Barnes has
taken on the mantle of Captain America
and is using his shield Steve Lutz Bucky
keep the shield and in turn he uses the
energy
shield Steve then leads a team of Secret
Avengers on covert missions in which he
uses the energy shield the whole entire
time in replacement of his old shield
this lines up kind of perfectly to where
we're at in the MCU right now after the
events of civil war at the end of the
movie he gave up his shield and then
with the events of infinity war we
learned that between the events of Civil
War and the events of infinity war
Captain America Black Widow and Falcon
were on secret covert missions as the
secret Avengers
so again the comics and the MCU are kind
of lined up perfectly right now for
Captain America to wield the energy
shield and Captain America will
definitely need something new and
improved if he wants to try and take on
Thanos again but let me know your
thoughts on this theory in the comments
below do you think Captain America will
wield his energy shield than Avengers 4
and if so how excited are you to see it
let me know and don't forget to
subscribe comment and like this video so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything related to
Avengers 4 thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]